hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy and many of you all know about
another project another not-for-profit
that i've been involved with known as
schoolhouse.world which is all about
giving folks free tutoring and we do
that by finding amazing volunteer tutors
now the tutors we've been finding they
found a lot of reward just being able to
to their other folks but we want to make
sure that they also get other rewards
because if you can tutor something not
only does that mean that you know the
material but it also means that you can
communicate you have empathy you want to
spend your time doing good for others so
we were excited last year when
university of chicago said that they
were going to use someone's tutor
reputation as a way to evaluate students
applying for university chicago and just
a few weeks ago mit also announced that
they were putting schoolhouse.world
profiles as an optional thing that
students could submit and the schools
will look at them to get a sense of the
amazing tutors we're finding this right
over here is the tutor profile and the
transcript for karen g who's a high
school student and you can see that
she's hosted a ton of sessions 543
learners impacted 33 countries reached
864
positive ratings and you can see what
people are saying about her my friend
and i have been trying to go to every
single one of your sessions for the past
few weeks and we literally love you and
we can go after page after page of what
everyone is saying about her and then
what also fellow tutors are saying so
she's getting feedback to become a
better and better tutor and we also have
the certification mechanism which is
qualifying her to tutor in specific
units to show all of the things that she
has gotten mastery in this right over
here is the tutor profile for kate
pierce so once again another incredibly
amazing high school student 326 sessions
hosted over a thousand positive ratings
and what people are saying about kate
right over here she was very reassuring
and and very and checks in with us
whenever we needed help or got a
question wrong very helpful and patient
and broke things down these are things
that you can't get just through
traditional transcripts the ability of
someone like kate to communicate and
empathize with other folks so if you're
a university or an employer who's really
interested in these types of students i
encourage you to click on that form in
the link on this post and we can reach
out to you and figure out how we can
build a relationship so that you can
discover amazing talent from the tutors
at schoolhouse.world so any young folks
out there especially high school
students or college students who are
interested in tutoring i encourage you
to check out schoolhouse.world and i am
going to work with you and work for you
to ensure that the rest of the world
college admissions officers and
eventually internships and employers and
scholarships recognize that one of the
best ways to prove what you know and
give back to others is to tutor on
schoolhouse.world